Nhanh quan đến phố khổ bớm ngày 18,7,
tại huyện Chương Quinh của tính đặc lắc nhiều Chương phố và tổ chương quý tề đánh lên
an mạnh mẽ hình vì giá măn vô nhân tính của các lửa tượng khổ bố.
Mình biết nhìn trong thời gian đầy khi Việt Nam thực hiện giãn tổ lối với đủ tượng khổ bố là
ý quình bất đặc tự thay làm về nước một số thế lực thu立
tổ chức phản động lưu vòng và các tổ chức mang dành nhân quình thiếu thuyền chi
lại vụ cáo Việt Nam đang á quình của người dân tổ chức số kêu quản dữ luận có tế
kàng thiệp ngăn càng việc dân độ.
Ê quình bất đặc lối tổ lối tổ chức của người thượng vi công liy
thì tổ an như tình đặc lắc tương phản người năm tổ với tổ dành khủ bố
và bị khách tổ quản chức năng gặp của định truyền á đầm miệnh.
Hành vi của ý quình bất đặc lực sau định là tích nọc, suy rục,
chỉ đạo các lối tổ chồng nất chở đi bố khí lên kế hoạch
và tổ chức bố lắc.
Tổ khi vụ việc ngày 1 tháng xóa khu hành bà,
tổ chức của chúng tôi là một tổng như kế tổ chức.
Có thăm ra trong kế bánh để cũng bố đó và chúng tôi đã mặt thân tôi.
Ná cũng như là chỉ đạo tổng kế vụ việc tấn công tru sở con ăn 2 xả dạc tổ và dạ thiếu
và nhằm bối mục ních là cấp chính quyền và tấn công chính quyền và cấp vụ khí
để gọi là thành lập nhảnh rất địa gà, tế nguyên thì bằng thân đả hả?
Ngay ra kế hậu qua, rất nghiêm trọng.
Tập miệt là tổ ý, chỉ ra định nạn nhân và những người bị 2,
tổ ý mong ra định thả lối cho tổ ý.
Thời đẹp sẽ sử, í quên bất đặc và nắm lối từ 3 năm là chúng tải nước ngoài.
Ngay 2 mấy sảo thảo mình một năm 2 ngần khu trả mai lâm,
tổ án hình sự thái lăn, lại phía thuốc thầm.
Ná gà quy định dẫn lộ í quên bất đặc,
được qua, việc nằm đã hoạt tất, việc dẫn lộ lối từ 2.
Quảy chình dẫn lộ í quên bất đặc, đà mạo ăn toàn,
đúng quy định của thóc lột, thái nước và các dựng ước của tế mà việc năm và thái lăn là thành viên.
Đây là mình chứng thể hiện bất quan hệ hỗng dị hợp tác của hai nước.
Nhanh chả lại công bằng trước các bạn nhé vụ khủng bố,
nằm vào công li, lẽ phạch, nhưng thực hiện.
Lúc đầu của rất là căng thẳng nhưng mà sau khi mình thấy cái căng bộ của ngàn họ của bố,
với sự không có gì gọi là đây gọi hợp hình được gì hết.
Chứ nên là mình cũng thái mái, tổng bên đề nó chuyện với họ.
Về hợp xin độ lối tự về Việt Nam để chắc thành bản ăn là có hiểu lực là nhằm là bảo tính tổ phóc lột.
Mọi biển đều có nghĩa vụ thí hành ăn theo cuối định.
Không ai được phép chốn tránh chắc nhẹ mằng bất kỳ lý gần nào.
Phạm nhăn được lối sự công bằng nhé đạo.
Đúng cuối định của phóc lột Việt Nam và các cảm kết quốc tế mà Việt Nam là thành viên.
Mệ này ở đây là một phóc mê nhưng đó hardly và thích bụng giấy hộ.
Bộ này làm một bông thích khách như bạn có một việc khách b recorded thích đườngて,
rồi thì mình sẽ giảnh các tốt đúng làm ăn đường.
Algo vàng đường cởng giảm vàng đường cởng giảm vàng đường cởng giảm vàng giảm vàng giảm vàng giảm vàng giảm.
Tên giảm vàng giảm vàng giảm vàng giảm.
Đó, rồi mà, đánh tìm đợi tây lệ có.
Anh pinh lở là trong trải tham bụng mình thì có phán tâm đến anh quyết.
Nhiều là ăn ống thích hả tây vẫn mình thử lực.
Chẳng trải ngu học không bị đánh đất.
Vìa thực hiện công tác dẫn độ và nằm bảo thí hành án không chỉ để hợp sướng nếu mình của phát luật.
Mặc còn là bái học cảnh tình cho những lối tượng lời dụng các chờ bài dẫn độ tôn giáo,
để tiếp độ trúng phá, xâm phạc, lịch an ninh cú ra.